جوعانين جوعانين جوعانين جوعانين ماذا
سناكل يا حلوين جوعانين
جوعانين ماذا سناكل يا حلوين يا حلوين
خضروات وفواكه فواكه خضروات وفواكه فواكه
هيا نحضرها في
[موسيقى]
الحين لدينا ثمار مختلفه خضر بالفائده
غنيه ولدينا احلى فواكه كم هي طيبه
وشهيه لدينا ثمار مختلفه خضر بالفائده
غنيه ولدينا احلى فواكه كم هي طيبه وشهيه
تفاح كيوي واناناس فيها اغلى
فيتامينات والموز معشوق الناس بطيخ مع
كرزات تفاح كيوي واناناس فيها اغلى
كرزات
جوعانين
جوعانين جوعانين
جوعانين جوعانين جوعانين ماذا سناكل يا
حلوين يا حلوين جوعانين جوعانين جوعانين
ماذا سناكل يا حلوين يا حلوين خضروات
وفواكه فواكه خضروات وفواكه فواكه هيا
نحضرها في
[موسيقى]
الحين طماطم خس وخيار نختار لكم احلى خضر
ومع الاف كعدو يا صغار حبات من اشهى جزر
طماطم خص وخيار نختار لكم احلى خضر ومع
الافوكادو يا صغار حبات من اشهى جزر
فراوله خوخ بالطي وفي السل ل
ليمون ولدينا توت وينب منجا تمر
معتين
فراوله خوخ بطيخ وفي السله
ليمون
ولدينا توت وعنب مجا تمر مع
تين
جوعانين
جوعانين جوعانين
h